In the last video on exponential
functions, we saw
that functions of the form,
y is equal to some
number to the x.
Say y is equal to 3x,
which was what we
used in the last video.
We saw that these grow very,
very, very quickly.
So the shape of the graph that
we got in the last video looks
something like this.
It gets very close to 0,
slowly pulls away from
0, and then, bam!
It starts to explode.
This, of course, is when
x is equal to 0.
So the y-intercept there
is y is equal to 1.
But the important thing is it
just grows super fast. But
this was the case where the
base in the exponential
function is greater then 1.
Here, it's 3.
If it's 2, it'll still
grow quickly.
If it was 10, it would
grow even faster.
What I want to talk a little bit
about in this video, and
really just introduce you to the
idea, is the notion of an
exponential decay function.
So this is an exponential
growth function.
An exponential decay function
has essentially, as its base,
a number less than 1.
So an example of an exponential
decay function
would be y is to 1/3
to the x power.
This would be exponential
decay.
And notice, another way I could
write this, 1/3 is the
same thing as 3 to
the negative 1.
So it's 3 to the negative
1 to the x power.
I could also write this as 3
to the negative x power.
This and this are equivalent.
That's another interesting way
to think about exponential
decay functions.
It could either be kind of a
standard positive exponent,
with a base that's less than
1, or you could have a base
larger than 1, but you're going
to have a negative as
the exponent.
So let's plot this, just to
get the general shape.
And the shape will always
be consistent.
I'm going to do it for 1/3,
but it's going to have a
similar shape for 1/2, or
for 1/10, or for 1/100.
It'll just be scaled
up or down.
So let's plot a few.
Let's have some x values and
let's have some y values.
So let's start with
some small values.
So let's say that x is
equal to negative 3.
Well, what is 1/3 to the
negative 3 power?
1/3 to the negative 3, that's
the same thing as 3 to the
third power, which
is equal to 81.
Let's do another point.
What about negative 2?
1/3 to the negative 2 power.
It's the same thing as 1 over--
Sorry, it's equal to 1
over 1/3 squared, which the
same thing as 3 squared.
You just take the inverse of
the number, get rid of the
negative and that is equal
to equal to 9.
Oh, I got this one
wrong up here.
3 cubed isn't 81.
That's 3 to the fourth.
3 times 3 times 3 is 27.
My brain is malfunctioning.
What about when x is equal to
negative 1, then you have 1/3
to the negative 1 power.
which is just 3.
What about when x
is equal to 0?
When x is equal to 0, remember,
anything to the 0
power is 1.
And then let's go to a couple
of larger numbers.
When x is equal to
1, what is y?
1/3 to the 1 power is 1/3.
Let's do one more.
When x is equal to 2, we have
1/3 squared, which is 1/9.
So let's plot this exponential
decay function right here.
I want to draw it reasonably
neatly.
And all of these values, once
again, are positive because
our base was positive.
So it looks like that.
So let's say that this
is 10, 20, 30.
Let's start at negative
3, negative 2,
negative 1, 0, 1, 2.
So when x was negative
3, y was 27.
Right about there.
When x was negative
2, y was 9.
Which is right about there.
When x is negative 1, y is 3.
Right about there.
x is 0, y is 1.
x is 1, y is 1/3, until
we decline like this.
Let me draw it a little
bit neater than that.
The decay functions are
harder for me to draw.
We'll draw it in
reverse order.
No, that's even worse.
One more shot.
I think you get the
general idea.
That's my best shot
right there.
So you see, a decay function
is kind of
reversed around the y-axis.
We start from a large quantity
and we decay
very, very, very quickly.
So in either case, exponential
functions, whether we have
exponential growth or
exponential decay-- Let me
make sure that you understand
this growth applies to this
thing up here.
This is exponential decay.
And either way, in exponential
functions,
things happen quickly.
Now, using what we know about
exponential decay functions,
let's do an actual
word problem.
Let me read it here.
It says, a person is infected
by a bacterial infection.
And they say, when he goes to
the doctor, the population of
bacteria is 2 million.
So at the start, he's got 2
million little critters, 2
million bacteria.
The doctor prescribes an
antibiotic which kills
bacteria, that reduces the
bacteria to 1/4 of its
population each day.
So we have the antibiotic and
it cuts down the population.
So it reduces population
to 1/4 of the previous
population each day.
So they ask us a couple
of things.
Draw the graph of the size of
the bacteria population
against time in days.
So let's draw this.
So day, and then population.
So let's say on day 0, before
you went to the doctor, your
population is going
to be 2 million.
Now on day 1, what happens?
On day 1 you've taken their
antibiotic, right?
The antibiotic is starting
right there.
So it reduces it to 1/4 of
your previous population.
So now your population is
going to be 1/4 times 2
million, which is equal
to 500,000.
Then on day 2, what happens?
On day 2, it's going
to be 1/4 of this.
It's going to be 1/4 of
your previous day.
1/4 of 1/4 of your previous
2 million.
So it's 1/4 of this 500,000
which is 125,000.
I think you're starting to see
the pattern that's emerging.
On day 3, what's
it going to be?
It's going to be 1/4
times this thing.
So it's going to be 1/4 times
this 1/4 times 1/4 times 1/4
times 2 million.
Which is essentially 125,000
divided by 4, but the
important thing is, I want
you to see this pattern.
In general, the population
at day n-- Let me write
this in a new color.
The population on day n is going
to be equal to what?
It's going to be equal to 1/4
to the n power, right?
This is day n.
On the third day, it was
1/4 to the third
power times 2 million.
On day 2, it was 1/4 to
the second power.
On day 1 it was 1/4 to
the first power.
On day 0, there is actually
1/4 to the 0 power, right?
That's 1.
So it's 1/4 to the nth power
times our starting population,
times 2 million.
And if we were to graph it,
using at least just the points
that we have here, we're only
going to be dealing with
positive x's.
So on day 0, we start
at 2 million.
So let's say this
is a million.
So on day 0, we're
at 2 million.
On day 1, we're at
1/4 of that.
So let's say that's 1 million,
so then that is 500,000.
On day 2, we're 1/4 of
this, so this is
250,000, that's 125,000.
And then on day 3, we're
1/4 of that.
So you see the population of our
bacteria really goes down
very quickly.
It never gets quite to 0.
We're always going to
have some bacteria.
Well, eventually you're going
to have 1 bacteria, and you
can get the antibiotic.
And it's going to have a 1/4
chance of hitting it so,
maybe, eventually you'll get to
0, but it slowly gets to 0.
But the absolute number
decreases very, very fast.
Now they also ask us, find
the size of the bacteria
population 10 days after the
drug was first taken.
So that's just n
is equal to 10.
So it's going to be equal
to 1/4 to the tenth
power times 2 million.
Let's take our calculator out
to calculate to this.
So let's take 1 divided by
4 to the tenth power.
That's equal to this very small
number times 2 million.
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, is equal to--
we're only going to have
a 1.9 bacteria after
the tenth day.
This is going to be equal to 1.9
bacteria, so pretty much
most of the bacteria is
gone by the tenth day.